là où ça bouge ce soir avec deux villes
à l'honneur tout d'abord alençon une
initiative originale pour visiter la
ville
on ira voir l'office de tourisme et
ensuite on passera à honfleur avec
sabine daniel qui fait son cinéma
comme d'habitude deux comme je vous le
disais à l'instant on va essayer de
visiter un petit peu alençon voir le
patrimoine dans leur riga toute une
documentation évidemment ici à l'office
de tourisme
mais sandrine je crois qu'il ya une
autre façon de visite à londres sont
maintenant oui maintenant sur un an sans
nous pouvons visiter la ville grâce à
une application
comment on peut faire eh bien venez je
vous ai dit on y va alors comment ça se
passe alors très simplement vous
téléchargez l'application visite à
l'intention votre smartphone vous venez
positionner votre téléphone à chacune
intérêt dans ce petit outil pour la paix
la carte board vous ne serez très
simplement vous positionnez votre
smartphone vous refermez et à chaque
monument vous positionnez votre tête et
vous pouvez accéder à l'intérieur de
bâtiments de la ville d'alençon tab aux
yeux marc bouche vous occuper de ce
procédé je vous avais un autre boîtier
avec vous dans la main c'est quoi en
fait ce beacon qui est installé il reste
cinq antennes dans la commune et là à
côté la basilique on en a 1 d'installer
qui est détecté par le téléphone par le
signal bluetooth qui permet de
géolocaliser le téléphone est donc de
donner à l'application d'information du
lieu est donc aux visiteurs d'avoir les
informations qui remontent donc là cette
fois ci y voit ce que vous aviez c'est
la basilique et les éléments la
basilique
et là on est devant le château d'alençon
mais malheureusement il est fermé donc
on peut pas le visiter on fait comment
mais on utilise l'application mobile qui
a été développée et donc voilà une
application innovante qui permet de
visiter l'intérieur du château
cette initiative d'ici de la vida
lancions elle est unique en france
donc on est fiers comme en normandie
d'avoir une initiative originale ça va
se développer ailleurs on espère bien
que d'autres suivront l'exemple
d'alençon et cette belle initiative
effectivement qui couplent plusieurs
technologies et qui permet de faire une
visite virtuelle aujourd'hui
géolocalisés une innovation normande
eh bien nous jacques nous allons
défendre les couleurs de honfleur
honfleur où les habitants ont la chance
et le privilège d'avoir un cinéma en
plein centre ville et je ne suis pas un
gros calibre d'accord alors avec jean
luc louvel pourparlers avec le directeur
de ce cinéma
alors d'abord combien c'est le tarif
plein ici 6 euros 6 euros se cacher non
ceux généralement on est autour de 2,8
euros et cessera 8090 depuis près de dix
ans n'a pas augmenté les tarifs
c'est une politique de la salle oui
c'est une politique de la salle et du
maire de ne pas subir des augmentations
de tva qu'on a eue de pas répercuté et
de rester accessible pour les enfants on
a pris l'option de passer par un
programmateur en début d'année où là on
arrive à voir des films un peu plus
récents et avoir un peu plus de fil ou
est ce que c'est ce qui explique le fait
que vous ayez une augmentation de
fréquentation 50%
on est passé de 10 séances hebdo 1 14
ans cède 2,21 une séance de pendant les
vacances scolaires et on a maintenant
trois quatre films par semaine
on peut proposer au public rai pourquoi
ici a roof leur avez vous choisi de
faire un cinéma municipal c'est un vrai
choix politique c'est un vrai choix
politique de le garder il est ouvert
depuis 1989 et c'est un cinéma
effectivement en régie municipale
avec des salariés qui sont de la
municipalité et c'est un choix de ces
politiques pour être sûr d'offrir ou en
fleuret une carte culturelle variée avec
des tarifs qui sont bon marché et de
garantir ce service là où ont fleuri ici
aussi des festivals des choses de les
lier à particulier tout à fait un
festival du fémur russe qui débute fin
novembre et nous avons des films
familiaux des comédies des films
d'action des films d'art et c'est des
documentaires et à partir de maintenant
nous allons voir également des
spectacles parisiens par exemple ou des
balais qui vont être filmée et
retranscrit retransmis au cinéma pour un
prix modique les honfleurais peuvent
même profiter de quelques sorties
nationales petit peu trop une assiette
vous les faites à l'unité du boulot
super et puisqu'on est en fleurs
rentabilisant déplacement jeu je voulais
vous rappeler que le musée eugène boudin
accueille jusqu'au 3 octobre une très
belle exposition intitulée être jaune au
temps des impressionnistes
vous avez bien connu ça jacques et
toujours grâce au mobile voici une
information très importante ça se passe
samedi prochain à pont-l'évêque c'est le
premier salon livres et cinéma les
traversée littéraire plus de 50 auteurs
régionaux et nationaux seront présents
et puis aussi stéphane brizé qui
projettera son dernier film sur guy de
maupassant avec toute l'équipe du film
qui sera là à pont l'évêque
ce sont les traversée littéraire de
pont-l'évêque première édition de ce
salon est audible les cloches les
cloches est beau les cloches d'alençon